When you think of Mount Everest,...
...you might think that this mountain is not something you would dare to challenge.
However, as a novice to climbing, you can also enjoy all the extraordinary...
...and imposing views and activities that this giant has to offer.
How about putting in your resume that you have climbed up Mount Everest?
Interviewers would think of you as an enthusiastic person.
If you decide to go, here are some things to know.
While skilled climbers start to ascend via the northeast ridge,...
...the last stop for ordinary travelers is the Northern Base Camp.
This camp is at an altitude of 5,208 meters,...
...and porters with animals supply the camp with necessaries.
Vehicles can also reach the camp during the summer using the Friendship Highway.
Trekking along the Base Camp is the most popular route in the Himalayas.
You will remember the panoramic views of the Himalayas from the Base Camp forever.